plairait vu les cas la parole est à
monsieur jean leonetti sur le président
mac pas ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le premier ministre c'est premier
ministre dans le contexte des événements
tragiques du 13 novembre un fait un fait
à mes yeux majeur choc nos concitoyens
et aggravent leur chagrin et leur colère
un certain nombre de terroristes étaient
des français pour nous les républicains
que les choses soient claires aucune
excuse qu'elles soient culturelles ou
sociales n'est possible pour ceux qui
ont commis des actes barbarie et pour
ceux qui les approuvent
la france n'est pas coupable de
discrimination religieuse parce qu'elle
est laïque d'exclusion sociale parce
qu'elle est généreuse d'apartheid parce
qu'elle n'est pas raciste et elle n'a
pas non plus à s'excuser auprès de
quiconque de son passé ou de son
histoire qui a fait ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui les drapeaux français sont à
nos fenêtres
les parlementaires et le gouvernement
presque à l'unanimité chantent la
marseillaise
qu'est ce que veut dire être français ce
n'est ni une religion ni une origine ni
la couleur de la peau c'est comme le
disait renan un héritage appartenait g
et une communauté de destin ses idées
ses valeurs pour réussir l'intégration
doivent se développer à l'école et dans
nos familles avec autorité on n'a pas le
droit d'interdire de caricaturer dans le
pays de la liberté
on n'a pas le droit de voisey voiler la
face d'une femme dans le pays de
l'égalité on n'a pas le droit de prêcher
la haine dans le pays de la fraternité
on n'a pas le droit de placer les lois
religieuses au dessus des lois de la
république
à cause de la laïcité monsieur le
premier ministre
êtes vous prêt avec détermination au
delà des symboles et des paroles à faire
en sorte de faire respecter avec
intransigeance dans la pratique et dans
les faits les principes républicains qui
sont liées à notre identité nationale
française
merci monsieur leonetti la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député jean leonetti vous
avez raison ce qu'on a voulu attaquer en
janvier déjà
ce sont des hommes des femmes bien sûr
mais les symboles la liberté
d'expression la liberté de caricature ce
qu'on a voulu attaquer c'est l'ordre
l'ordre républicain
à travers les forces de l'ordre et ses
policiers qui sont tombés ce qu'on a
voulu mettre en cause c'est notre
diversité en s'en prenant à des français
juifs parce qu'ils étaient juifs
ce qu'on a voulu abattre touché le 13
novembre dernier
c'est un art de vivre c'est parfaitement
dit d'ailleurs malheureusement dans lé
communiqué de l'état islamique de dèche
san art de vivre
c'est une manière de consommer c'est
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
c'est la culture c'est là c'est la
musique et l'on face à cela il faut une
réponse
ça a été dit plusieurs fois ici dans cet
hémicycle surtout les banques c'est bien
sûr l'autorité de l'état
c'est la guerre dans laquelle nous
sommes engagés c'est la lutte contre le
terrorisme mais c'est aussi vous l'avez
dit avec vos mots et je crois qu'ils
sont forts c'est la république dans tous
ses aspects qu il s'agit pas uniquement
de l'incantation des mots qu'il faut
prononcer c'est ce patriotisme qui est
là présent qu'on sent partout dans le
pays
dans toutes les catégories de la
population dans toutes les générations
c'est l'amour du drapeau c'est l'amour
de la france que nous devons chérir
c'est l'amour de l'hymne national on a
trop laissé d'ailleurs sifflet cet hymne
national dans le stade et dans les
manifestations
c'est l'apprentissage des valeurs de la
laïcité et c'est tout l'engagement bien
sûr au sein de l'école et l'engagement
notamment des enseignants qui sont
formés depuis des mois à la transmission
des valeurs et de la laïcité c'est pour
qu'à un gamin dans un de nos quartiers
populaires dans une classe ne puisse
plus dire que son ennemi c'est le juif
est malheureusement vous le savez nous
avons trop entendu cela au cours de ces
dernières années
c'est l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes vous l'avez rappelé et donc c'est
l'application stricte et absolu de la
loi qui interdit les signes religieux
tous les signes religieux à l'école mais
aussi bien sur la burqa le voile
intégral dans l'espace public et le
ministre l'intérieur encore rappelé aux
forces de l'ordre et au préfet combien
ces lois devaient être appliquées
partout sur tout le territoire parce
qu'on est là face un symbole majeur et
qui doit être en permanence respecter
oui ce sont tous ces symboles tu sont
tous ces maux de ce sont tous ces actes
que nous devons faire vivre au sein de
la république
on a voulu attaquer un modèle un art de
vivre un pays et un peuple libre et qui
parle au monde entier et donc notre
réponse c'est aussi l'affirmation de ses
valeurs et je suis convaincu que nous
pouvons tous deux retrouvés autour de
ses valeurs
il ya peut-être deux autres éléments que
je voudrais souligner rajouter à votre
propos le premier vous le soulignez
c'est la fraternité la réponse à la
barbarie la réponse au terrorisme
c'est aussi un modèle de vivre ensemble
c'est le respect des autres quelle que
soit sa religion son lieu de naissance
et sa couleur de peau vous l'avez
parfaitement dit la france ça n'est pas
une religion ce n'est pas uniquement un
héritage c'est une manière de vivre et
de regarder le monde et si nous sommes
français c'est parce que nous partageons
des valeurs qui nous sont communes
et puis le dernier élément c'est aussi
notre propre comportement
c'est notre propre comportement quand on
a la chance d'avoir une belle démocratie
comme la nôtre même si elle connaît
évidemment ses défis ses problèmes et
ses fractures
chacun doit prendre ses responsabilités
nous même ceux qui gouvernent ceux qui
ont gouverné ceux qui aspirent à
gouverner par notre propre comportement
partout mais aussi chaque français est
le premier rendez vous monsieur le
député c'est aussi dimanche prochain la
meilleure manière aussi de conforter la
démocratie c'est de voter et voter pour
la république pour le groupe écologiste